Couple of implementation issues.
In general, warping is not,
warping is one of those things that
in principle should be really easy.
In practice you always make mistakes,
I will say that MATLAB does a very fine
job of, of allowing you to do
warping in particular ways so
if you are using MATLAB or
Octave it's easy.
And I think within python nonpie
openCV accomplishes as well.
The other thing,
in order to make this work and
actually we'll get to this when
we do the whole multi-scale.
Is its often useful to sort of
take a nice bit of a low-pass
filter of your images.
Smooth things out,
why do you want to do that?
To get sort of your smoother
derivatives as, as things work.
And we'll talk more
about that next time.